hey I'm Dave Rubin welcome to the Rubin
report and this week we have a meaty
show for you we got info we got facts
there is a lot going on in the world you
know sometimes they say it's a slow news
week slow news day not this week a lot
happening and I got two great guests for
you
first off comedy legend can I call you
comedy legend will you accept it miss
Elaine Boosler yes whatever matter yes
in the Loch Ness monster spirit I will
accept the legend comedy legend Elaine
are one of my favorite ladies and TYT
legend I can call you that can I not the
way the news anchor way anyway Ana
Kasparian
I've heard a lot about you so I'm very
excited about hosting with you I'll say
my music hosting I keep going into that
habit but guesting with you testing well
we can switch spots we'll do a little
round robin thing we can each take a
topic and see what happen like you know
tennis we'll just rotate yeah okay
exactly all right well this is YouTube
so we got to get to it fast all right so
- as I said this has been a big news
week and today's just Monday craziness
is happening so the DOJ the Department
of Justice it has come out that they
have obtained two months of phone
records from the AP that is The
Associated Press and people are going
bonkers and by the time we get this to
you tomorrow we may have a whole set of
new facts so we're going to talk about
in a kind of wide-ranging way but
basically they they took these records
without anyone knowing now it's coming
out that maybe some of the higher-ups
did know and the AP released a statement
about it let's take a look at that this
is from the AP president and CEO Gary
Pruitt he said there can be no possible
justification for such an over there can
be no possible justification for such an
over broad collection of telephone
communications of The Associated Press
and its reporters these records
potentially reveal communications with
confidential sources across all of the
news gathering activities undertaken by
the AP during a two-month period provide
a roadmap to the APS new
gathering operations and disclose
information about the ApS activities and
operations that the government has no
conceivable right to know okay pretty
heavy stuff but you're laughing already
tape well I I can't wait to hear some
like light-hearted humor about this
because it's something that really of
course rubs me the wrong way is the
number of the press you know you don't
want to know that the government or you
don't want to hear that the government
can come in and just take two months
worth of records from journalists and
reporters now from what we're hearing at
this point is that it has to do with a
March 2012 article that was written
about the seat yet CIA finding out about
an al-qaeda plot to attack the US with
an airline right so they were able to
figure it out and make sure that that
terrorist attack never went through
which sounds like pretty good right
serve our CIA that sounds good but
doesn't get to the heart of the problem
does it yeah I guess it doesn't get to
the heart of the problem which is
probably the reason why they want to get
access to the records and figure out who
the sources are why is it that the APA
or the AP had sources who was the source
and what other type of information is
that source sharing with media yeah so
whether they're doing something good or
not should the government be allowed of
course not and if you remember after
9/11 they were supposedly listening for
chatter on you know alleged people on
lists but it turned out they were
listening to everyone they were
listening at Tom Cruise make love to his
fiancee and they were they were outside
of buildings listening to celebrity so
it's this shouldn't be so outrageous for
people as a new thing it's not a new
thing and people are outraged now
because it's them they're the people
used to report on it but now it's them
well done Elaine Boosler you got to my
second point that is the part that's
driving me crazy about this because
although I think this is horrific and
the government shouldn't be spying on us
and citizens much less the reporters and
that whole thing the media is outraged
now because it's the media because just
last week it was shown that the
Department of Justice has already said
without warrants they can go into our
emails into our chats in our
Facebook's so in a way though is this
possibly good because finally the media
is gone oh well you can't come and step
on us so it's only good if they can back
them off I don't think that anything's
gonna back them off I mean once and I
you know people say leave Bush alone you
know I'm still blaming Reagan it's still
current to me George Bush but you know
you elected not you but certain folks
elected government who had no feelings
about privacy and and nothing was sacred
and overstepped in every possible
direction this is the the stepchild of
it this is the upshot and this is what
we're left with and if people don't
start voting better this is what we
gonna have yeah and I would kill someone
if I found out they were eavesdropping
on Barry Singh how many nights did she
order pizza out ever cook Chinese pizza
this woman has never cooked well just a
$5,000 stove disgusting she's a horrible
person it's more about the shame people
think it's about like naked pictures
food and I'm always ordering extra soda
so we'll think there's not just me alone
even though it's Terry how many pairs of
chopsticks well if you have to ask I
better say four and also keep in mind
that the media was really what push the
narrative after 9/11 about how it's
important for the government to have
access to certain records and it's
important for the government to do
certain things that might violate our
privacy because it's in the name of
national security so now as you
mentioned it was a really great point
yeah the tables turn and they can't they
can't handle it we come to this I mean
it was the original statement you know
he who gives up a little bit of security
a little bit of privacy for a little bit
of security deserves neither and now we
have a lot more than losing a little bit
of privacy and a little bit of security
and you guys do you guys fear that
because obviously the media and us that
are on the progressive side of this
thing we like let's say Obama more than
we like let's say Bush that there's this
inherent feeling that we should go easy
on here
how dare they when it comes to civil
liberties I mean Obama's record has been
just as bad if not worse than Bush's you
say Jerome yes your own strikes
signature strikes where you don't even
know if you're targeting the right
person but you still do it anyway and
then when you do double taps where you
do a drone strike and then you have you
know the first responders show up and
then you drone them I mean come on Obama
has been horrible when it comes to civil
liberties kill this lack of transparency
I think that we should hope it rises and
being able to kill American citizens if
if they're declared an enemy of the
country and they're American citizens
due process as due process you're next
you cannot stand for this and it has to
change and he we signed the Patriot Act
it led to all right and yet somehow we
still there's a feeling like oh that's
Bush's fault or Bush's fault
so it's honorable but it's Obama's baby
now and he was supposed to close it yeah
there's too much going on that's wrong
and you know look I'd always rather help
Obama than the other side in there for
so many social reasons but he's not you
know the great savior there's a lot
that's wrong and people need to speak up
it's never over and that's the really
difficult thing about Obama you know he
is great when it comes to social issues
you want to support him because of the
fact that he did come out in support of
gay marriage and you know he isn't
anti-choice and and all that is really
important but our national security is
also very important and the way that
he's been handling it I think puts us at
more risk because it's creating
hostility toward the US right where they
didn't expect it at least they expected
it from Bush but they didn't accept a
great point made that if they went after
the Boston terrorists the way they go
after terrorists in Pakistan with the
drone strike five hundred people around
in the grandstands of the marathon would
have been killed also and we would have
said as we always do well you know
that's collateral damage but we got the
guys we needed to get it's unacceptable
it's unacceptable so speaking about
acceptable my final point on this I was
watching CNN today and Wolf Blitzer who
I I've become just merciless with this
guy because he is a robot sitting in a
giant computerised room he said that you
know to take the other side of this what
if the government was tracking al-qaeda
and then quote or whoever that's what he
said
or whoever like me ordering pizza or
your mom or whoever that's pretty broad
yeah doesn't this show like how duh like
that was afraid what's gonna happen here
is that because the media dumbs
everything down to the point where or
whoever who's who's whoever everybody
else which mean brings us back to the
point we all agree on no yeah yeah all
right how much are we ordering tell us
when the reves dropping him if they want
some - exactly
all right well more government stuff
this was really it's been a bad week for
Obama and it just started the IRS it has
now come out that they were targeting
the Tea Party and other Tea Party
related organizations they were using
phrases when they were hunting down
organizations such as Tea Party Patriots
nine twelve which is Glenn Beck's
organization and they flagged over a
hundred tea party related applications
and people are justifiably not happy
about this now I'm gonna guess and I
know both of you pretty well but you're
not big Tea Party chicks but that you're
not gonna be happy about this
and are you very why do you think I'm
not a big tea party chick I just I go to
those rallies and get wasted with all
these crazy-ass right-wingers know that
does set me apart I think that it
definitely has been a bad week for Obama
I don't know whether or not the Obama
administration actually played a role in
this and I don't really understand why
the IRS would be politically motivated
but if there is evidence indicating that
they are doing something that's
politically motivated then I'm against
it I don't think that they should do
that
I think the IRS doesn't make sense to me
because I feel like they're serious
instances of like you know unlawful tax
deductions whatever it is and then they
always go after little guys right and so
that always rubs me the wrong way but
then this - like you just you can't act
as a politically motivated you know
Department you have to you know audit
organizations
doing something that's unlawful right so
before you jump in it does seem to me
that this was clearly politically
motivated because if it wasn't
politically motivated they might have
gone after Media Matters or some some
left-wing things so political motivation
can we expect anything here's what
you're all missing yes okay they look
for red flags to audit you I've been
audited three times because I take a lot
off for travel and entertainment and you
know three times I've never owned a
penny but I have been audited you have
to go through a lot and it's fun isn't
it fine
so horrible and you know who makes money
is the tax preparers because they have
okay
now they look for red flags is this a
red flag
you're picketing with a sign that says I
don't pay taxes they party these idiots
are walking around at these big wooden
sites don't pay taxes we're against
taxes I don't pay check hello I don't
think it's anything about which party
they going that guy's not paying his
taxes so they should have expected it
actually a flag they're saying it's not
political at all they just they see a
fish on the line and that's it right do
you think though there's a danger in
that you know you mean that there's cuz
there's you're an idiot someone might
look at you well that the government
that maybe they shouldn't that they
shouldn't be just targeting one side you
know I always get pulled out of the line
at the airport just so they can pull out
the soir the dark-haired man next to me
and not be accused of racial profiling
so what you're saying is they're
supposed to audit me again just so they
cannot at the tea party know audit the
idiot was walking around with a big sign
in public saying I'm against paying
taxes see if you can get any money that
way do you think this is like a case of
Star Wars obi-wan Kenobi saying to Darth
Vader if you strike me down I'll come
back more powerful than you can possibly
imagine because that seems to me what
they might have done here with the tea
party it's like they're giving the Tea
Party exactly what they want this is the
part of the story that annoys me the
most because now you have these
right-wing pundits saying senior the
Obama administration everything is a big
conspiracy theory right and
this is working out perfectly for them
because even though it makes my blood
boil and I get dizzy just thinking about
it right now
you know politicians are prepping for
2016 right and so the Republicans are
making their list of things that they
can use to attack the Democrats and this
is a perfect example right oh look look
at what the IRS did under the Obama
administration oh look at how Hillary
Clinton handled Benghazi you know
Hillary Clinton is likely to run in 2016
yeah and we'll get to that discussion in
just a little bit but I hate that now
the
Conservatives have something that they
can use to their advantage to their own
political advantage yeah yeah it's so
true they can actually know when we're
running say oh gosh a few people died in
an embassy and a few people got audited
and all we have to fight back with his G
they put us into to illegal Wars for no
reason they could have prevented 9/11 he
knew it was coming
thousands of Americans died millions of
Iraqis are now G you know but Democrats
are notoriously bad at campaign maybe
will get better I hope so I certainly
hope so yeah I get better and you know I
just think being Benghazi is gonna
become a drinking game you know how many
times can you say this word and not may
the only way they're gonna make Benghazi
stick is if they can just actually say
Benghazi got oral sex and then people
will think about it that's the only
thing that matters the comedian and I
know a segue when I see it so all right
let's talk Benghazi then so there's so
much stuff going on with Benghazi it's
hard to kind of get all the facts in
place but basically on last September
11th our embassy in Libya was attacked
and then over the next couple days the
administration sort of rolled out these
talking points that Susan Rice was going
on all the talk shows and saying that
this was a spontaneous thing having to
do with that innocence of Muslims
YouTube video how am i doing so far
after that so now you reserved now oh my
god okay and then
no and then now it's come out last week
after a congressional hearing that this
was more of a premeditated attack that
they believe Muslim extremists were
involved and it was terrorism okay so
that's the take it away so does it
matter that was good you have a few dead
people this was a lot of wonderful
ambassador it's a horrible shame and
it's unfortunate but there was a
fabulous Huffington Post article last
week and I wish I remember the
gentleman's name and he said George
Bush's
15 Benghazi's and he listed the 15
embassy attacks under Bush's watch where
many people were killed and nobody made
this kind of hay out of it because they
weren't desperate for something to hang
their campaigns on to these people
should be ashamed of themselves wasting
the time they are supposed to be
advocating for their constituents
wasting their day at work on this crap
and these are the same people who voted
for cuts that cut back on security and
military personnel and all I think that
everyone knows at this point that
Republicans and conservative pundits on
like Fox News are using this to their
political advantage which makes it such
a despicable issue but at the same time
I do think that there are people out
there that are genuine and their
concerns and they're worried about the
way that the situation was handled so
there were a number of violent attacks
in the area prior to you know the attack
on the US consulate in Benghazi and so
there was a failure on the CIA's part
there and so that's a legitimate concern
first not the worst either and I think
that's a legitimate concern I don't
think the Obama administration handled
it properly by trying to use innocence
of Muslims as a scapegoat okay they
should have admitted that there was an
issue and that they were working to
investigate it and figure it out and
make their the CIA stronger when it
comes to determining other attacks yeah
let me just jump in there for a sec why
do you think they did that so quickly
because that's what Fox News seems not
for a moment that it was that well Fox
News seems to be pushing this idea or at
least Lindsey Graham is push they push
aside this matter in any actual until
heels
in a real discovers how you end things
like this okay here's what you do
Hillary Clinton should just come out and
say oh yes I wanted everyone to die yeah
you're right I wanted them to die I it
worked out perfectly
what can they then say well she sort of
did that yeah you know these guys are
not doing their job and they're just you
know it's total bait-and-switch for
governing leave this stuff to be let
this people rest in peace and do your
job yeah but do you think it matters
that they did roll out what now has
proven to sort of not be true at least
from the information like Colin Powell
bringing fake drugs to the yeah
the UN to say that it was enriched
uranium - but do you know do you think
it matters whether I think it matters
whether the role I don't know what their
intentions were I don't know if they
knew immediately like okay innocence of
Muslims was not really the problem but
let's find something to blame it on yeah
regardless of what their intentions were
they the media has used innocence of
Muslims or you know Obama using
innocence of Muslims as a way to
criticize him as a way to spin it and
make it seem like he found a cheap skate
scapegoat so that's an issue I think as
soon as it was clear that the CIA or
that the Obama administration had a lack
of intelligence they should have come
forward and said look there was an issue
we're being honest with the public but
there's always a lack of a conspiracy I
can't do it because you can't be a
decent honest human being in this
climate because anyway they're like
wolves now the other side they'll just
tear his throat out if he shows a bit of
that kind of honesty you could also be
you could also be honest and just say
like look with the CIA doesn't have like
super powers you know there are gonna be
flaws and intelligence and you can't
have nobody once they hear right that's
unfortunate right we all want that
intellection everybody wants to be made
safe I know they think they're being
made safe do you know why there hasn't
been an attack because no-one's planned
one yet you know maybe they've thwarted
some things but you cannot be made safe
you have to know that life goes on and
there are open holes for crazy people
I actually have a question because I'm
very curious to see what you think so
that there are rumors that the reason
why the right is really
holding on to this issue is because in
2016 you know the Republicans want to
use this as a way to attack Hillary car
they're gonna talk about it for three
more yes wondering is that a legitimate
thing to say well it seems obvious to me
that their use they're gonna hold this
thing so that it the fall goes on
Hillary and even today you could see
people were already saying is Obama now
gonna have to throw Hillary under the
bus as this thing keeps getting bigger
so it's ridiculous if you let me let
them determine that right but the point
is they have to it's like planting a
tree and they have to plant it so deep
right now that is flowers and three
years when they refer back to it they
have to play and what they've learned
from the Bush administration is the way
Bush and Cheney got away with everything
if you look at their speeches the words
nine eleven were a thousand times a week
you know it's not ten thousand times a
week yes if you repeat and you repeat
and you repeat and then that's what it
is so they're planting the Benghazi
seeds for later but there's nothing
there yeah but all right so as a
obviously someone on the more
progressive side us does do you fear
that if the progressives become as bad
using the use those same evil tactics
are we losing something in the process
of that well have we used the same evil
tactics you mean because he lied he lied
about yeah he tried to change this yeah
if the other side uses the bad tactics
to like what are we losing in the course
of that I'd like to see anybody know I'm
not willing to do anything but if he
made a mistake he made a mistake the
deaths had occurred already if he gave
the wrong story in a bad story or he
lied okay his lying did not cause more
deaths and he didn't lie to the point
where he could continue to kill the way
Bush and Cheney did in all these wars he
you know it's wrong he should you know
man up and move forward and not do it he
should man up I think the way that it
played out it made it seem like Obama
was refusing to admit the failures of
his own administration right and looking
for a cop-out so that made him I in a
lot of ways that made him look weak yeah
I agree there's something weird about
that we view the president in a way that
he should know everything at all times
why don't you know even with the IRS
thing why do we think that some
low-level employees now they're saying
low-level and it may have gotten
higher but that a bunch of guys in
Cincinnati we're doing something we
think well the president should know
about that we think the president should
know about the security at the elevator
in Benghazi we think that this guy
should basically be God which you know
unfair expectations of the President of
the United States but on the other hand
he's the president of the United States
you know what I mean gonna get it
nothing you're just gonna get it you
know of course you're a human you're
gonna have flaws that's totally
understandable but at the same time when
it comes to big issues like this you
should be briefed you should know what's
going on on the other hand because
people do think you should know every
single thing and I really think this
country has in the last few decades just
embrace such a lack of responsibility
and there is this daddy issue in this
country everybody wants this daddy to
take care of everything you know keep us
safe what did people do to keep
themselves safe they complain every time
they have to take their shoes off
there's so little responsibility and so
much counting on someone taking care of
you that they're just appalled or
frightened when there's a little break
and the power yeah that's really
interesting it brings up something I've
been thinking about lately that maybe in
America we need what they have in most
of Europe which is a prime minister who
really serves as what our president is
the guy doing policy and then have a
president that's more in line with
something you know ceremonial because I
feel like we get all our ceremonial
stuff out with Obama but maybe we need
really like some hardcore prick to be
the president and he's not a hardcore
prick but we love you me dancing with
Beyonce and all that stuff maybe we
emphasize the role of the vice president
I mean the Vice President was like the
most maybe the public gets a vote on who
the vice president is as well as opposed
to having lady do it I think I think
that once the president selected there
has to be the vice president from the
other party and then Congress has to
work with the two it well that's to win
I like it to hurt here first people
Elayne Boosler changing the face of the
nation yeah good luck with that
maybe you'll run how about that oh no
you know comedian I well we've had
several right and I think the amount of
times I've used certain words on my
facebook page we just eliminate me from
being able to run exactly as we sure
love cursing and writing alright but
that's a whole other topic why comedians
can never be present all right let's
move on let's get away from politics for
a little while television has actually
been a bigger bloodbath than even the
political landscape lately the up fronts
were this week and this is where the
network's tell you what's coming in the
upcoming season in this case the fall
and that usually comes with the big acts
where they chop away at all the crap
that nobody's watching and we got an
incredible set of charts here to show
you how many things were canceled here
we go
so this is ABC they got rid of 666 Park
Avenue Body of Proof don't trust the B
in apartment 23 happy endings how to
live with your parents for the rest of
your life last resort Malibu Country
private practice red widow zero our NBC
30 Rock's 1600 Penn animal practise
deception do no harm go on guys with
kids the new normal the office ready for
love Rock Center with Brian Williams
smash up all night and Whitney CBS CSI
New York Golden Boy the job made in
Jersey Partners rules of engagement and
Vegas and the CW I didn't even know they
were still on 902 uh no cults Emily
Owens m.d. Gossip Girl now just real
quick oh wait Fox wait now you forgot
about Fox Fox has basically the least of
the big boys because they're the only
one pulling ratings Bening Kate
cops which is moving to spike fringe the
mob doctor wait tops it's good yeah cops
is really people thought it got canceled
like two months ago but now it's going
over to we like donuts too yeah I love
watching cops when I was a kid Apple is
bad boys they're gonna do now 30 rock
duck wasn't canceled you don't have
planned end yes so a few of those shows
good point I
I mentioned they were the office also
went out via natural little age but it
went for a show doing her farewell tour
that you started in 1999 it's like a
Jewish goodbye alright let's go to the
car already
do you remember to send me the recipe
for the brown cake come on we have to go
she won't leave she won't leave and just
like the office yeah so there are ok so
there's a lot of things I want talk
about here because a lot of that was
just crap but no one's ever watched and
no one ever will watch but some of it
then was with some of the good stuff
what do you yeah so what do you think is
the is really going on here is this just
the changing attitudes of people in
television is it because we're all
getting stuff from Netflix now and we're
all watching on demand and all that crap
it's just crap it's crap yeah well I
think it's a combination of things a lot
of networks are now focusing on reality
TV because it's super cheap to produce
and the profit is massive people love to
watch train wrecks right and I think
that Netflix has a lot to do with it too
I just recently cancelled my cable
because I love watching old shows on
Netflix right now I'm into Breaking Bad
and I know that originally it was on TV
I was watching an old show the other day
it's called I Love Lucy yeah no not till
ten years after they went on Milty and
yeah I was the the first show that was
ever NTV 1952 a new popcorn when it came
in
by the way is exactly Harry on the show
that's because she saw Uncle Miltie
penis she did yeah he showed it to her
oh pretty good
do you know he was very famous for being
well endowed yes they had a huge contest
once at the Friars Club and someone said
I'm gonna challenge you and he said you
take it out and so if he said well you
go first and so the Challenger unzipped
his fly and he
he showed his penis and then he said
okay my uncle Miltie milton berle go
ahead and Milton Berle unzipped his fly
and he said that's not so big he said I
only took out enough to beat you in the
Friars Club and a gay bar right there
all right so far as better drinks yeah
but but speaking again one thing I
couldn't help but notice here is that a
bunch of gay programs disappeared the
new normal partners smash go on they all
had gay characters or gays storylines we
get like a ton of gay in the media now
but is it does is there something about
it that doesn't work for some reason in
a TV show is there something like we're
trying to push this thing on the
network's think gay gay guys are like
dogs if they put a dog on TV a gay you
know get with a gay guy on TV the gay
girls gonna run up to the Viggo I think
you know dogs well I mean you know it's
silly and really they put all these gay
characters in but that's not what gay
men watch gay men are watching
housewives rip the crap out of each
other on Bravo that's what they want to
see and they're not watching gay there
they go that guy is a briefcase is going
to wear great niceties and I do that Hey
look at that crazy woman with too much
makeup on that's what they're watching
for The Cooking Channel you should be
working for Andy Cohen yeah I'd see it I
could see it
yes Andy Cohen would run for me I think
I mean because Bravo is you know it's
very it's very specific right they don't
have a comedian sensibility Kathy
Griffin is on every 15 minutes I
cancelled not on my list she still does
a special every other week yeah yeah she
is on Bravo quite a bit I hated the
themes on her show though but I loved
her
I hated the theme song because they
played it over and over again throughout
the entire show yeah yeah I was
listening to an old Dean the other day
yeah you like it why don't you put a
ring on it
mm not easy when you drink we're all
over the place how does it that they
make this crap because we are all those
things I saw the commercials for all of
them and it's just you know it's crap
each time you watch it you know it's
crap and then they cancel it and then
they rehire the same people the same at
the same writers the same key grips and
they're messing the whole thing why fail
upwards in television yeah usually
there'll be one network that comes up
with a really great show idea
so like American Idol is an example
right and then you'll have like a
billion other shows to try to copy that
model and they don't work because people
already have American Idol yeah why do
people fail up in this crazy cause it's
very strange but it's so expensive this
business that you can walk in with the
most magnificent idea in the world if
you're an untried entity they will not
give it to you they would rather hire
someone who knows how to fail than an
untested person who may succeed it's
just too expensive yeah did you this is
total sidebar but in all your days I've
stand up and especially in the boom of
the 80s when everybody was getting a
sitcom left and right did you see guys
that you wrote for TV a lot
yeah in film I when I get tired of the
road I'd write for TV yeah but did you
ever see guys that you thought were
really incredible that didn't get the
break or the show versus the guys that
you thought were kind of whatever that
the yet I know I'm really putting you on
the spot here but no we'll shut the
camera no no um I think most people had
a good shot I think the problem with the
great comics that God a chance was again
it's like it's the Mets New York Mets
mentality they signed the greatest first
baseman who ever lived and they make him
a right fielder and that's what happened
to these comics they didn't follow
The Cosby example which was you take a
comics act like a man with five children
and put it into a situation they would
take great comics like John Mendoza who
I love and and he was just the most down
trodden serious and they give him I have
family and think no no that wasn't the
act they would take them and read they
change their position and that didn't
interpret into the show they needed to
take the persona they paid all that
money for and let that express itself in
the situation and they didn't again the
guys who know how to fail know how to
take you know bronze their gold medal
and that's what they did they bought
gold medals and Brunn's them alright
well we're doing this on YouTube and I
won't believe that this I told her it
was excuse me
I firmly believe it is the future just
stay for one more second would yes two
more sec one more Twitter one or two
more okay let's move on
so Sports Illustrated I think you guys
are gonna like this one
a new study by the Department of
Sociology at the University of
Louisville asked where all the women in
Sports Illustrated and researchers found
that out of seven hundred sixteen Sports
Illustrated issues published between
2000 and 2011 only 35 of them had covers
that featured female athletes and then
out of those 35 only 18 which came down
to 2.5% featured a female as the primary
or sole image and this was I think
bringing bikini well this does not
include the swimsuit issue
so that would bump the number to like so
is there any surprise here that Sports
Illustrated is not featuring female
athletes the way that we might like it
to all be equal yeah I mean I would love
to get angry at this story but you can't
get angry it's not Sports Illustrated
it's the consumer right consumers don't
really care about someone from the WNBA
you know they they want to see a woman a
sexy woman in a bikini or maybe some
dude that they idolize playing some sort
of sport that they like and but who who
buys Sports Illustrated
anymore like not to put them down but
who goes out and buys a Sports
Illustrated magazine like Matt the
magazine industry is in a lot of trouble
as it is and what they put on their
cover reflects what the consumer wants
and I think that's what we should really
focus on yeah well I don't know if the
consumer drives the magazine or the
magazines tell people who they should be
interested in because there's a
wonderful career going on that said I
mean when you say the WNBA that said
welcome to earth I mean that's pretty
much the percentage of women featured in
everything people say why aren't there
more female comics my line used to be
they strangled them at birth but really
why aren't there more female anything we
got in late because we weren't allowed
in and it takes a long time to get far
enough to be you know equal doctors
equal lawyers equal this equal that you
know it's it's a lot of it's hundreds of
years of catching up in professions yeah
and you're just that's the reflection of
the society men run it they're gonna
they want to see men it's men running it
for the most part okay so that's why are
they go naked men in the movies they
think women don't want to see them yes
we do but they don't clean they don't
want the guy in the movies to take out
more that will beat them take out just
enough to beat them or they don't want
the guy that's sitting there going oh
that guy's kind of sexy because then it
could really but you know yeah crumble
Society yes but the thing of course and
it would certainly impact my marriage
that man saw another man naked bye-bye
yeah good thing is it's that it's that
um you know they did a study and women
do want to see naked men in movies but
the guys making movies won't put them in
because they're men who don't you know
I'm so tired of seeing just only for
equal pay for equal forces married of
just women just and here's that shot cuz
we have to put that shot in for no
reason the woman's opening a can of
baked beans why is she topless I mean
she really she's opening can of beans
she's you know turning on the oven and
for some reason she forgot her shirt you
know please I know women react
differently to nudity though like I
don't like if I see a naked guy if I
just see someone's like flaccid penis I
don't think
oh god I gotta have there's your there's
your problem right there
honey you have to you have to join in
Forgetting Sarah Marshall you know in
one of the scenes in Forgetting Sarah
Marshall
there was a flaccid penis and this
started out with sports in your bus I'm
sorry
Sports Illustrated a it's like it's like
what was his name that football player
or the flaccid penis Johnson
Roethlisberger yes I remember
okay when Roethlisberger was sending out
his philosophy work for Anthony Weiner
he's getting back into politics although
Clinton won't back him because it's to
PETA see it's Joey
but we can get over Camus did politics
there's a limit the women in these cases
were not turned on by it so I think
that's the reason why you don't see like
nude men in movies as often as you seem
like winning some lovely male bodies and
movies and some swell pushes even on TV
and I think it should be a little more
equal just so you're not teaching young
men growing up that women are always the
objectified
object that it's always you know we're
always kind of on the bottom we're
always on the needy end we're always on
the part that's weak and and manipulable
I think it's just important to have you
know a little more parity right but in a
weird way don't you think Sports
Illustrated not putting women on is
actually you're saying though in a
bizarre way because you and I probably
buy it more if they were more
interesting women a featured you know
there are a few but no put it on the
newsstand at least someone would have an
image but do you think it's okay that
guys happen to like male sports more I
don't know many guys I don't know many
guys are like the WHS you don't know
many girls that do either but well
that's not ooh and I I don't think
that's fair I think they get short
shrift and I think first of all they
also play basketball the way basketball
began when men plated which is scrappy
basket ball instead of all these you
know Giants there's foot but now it's
Giants dunking at the rim and it it's
kind of like home run baseball it used
to be a scrappy little game they said
you know baseball it's not a bad pun
baseball has a game of inches and you
you worked your way you manufactured
runs it was much more exciting than the
home run in the early days when Babe
Ruth hit all those home runs the first
year they had to have a press conference
and apologize to the fans that he hit
that he had a promise not to hit the
home runs next year people hated it the
game was like boring which is ironic
because now the phrases chicks dig the
long ball so well but without steroids
there isn't much long ball in baseball
anymore so what's the difference but the
WNBA plays basketball the way it began
with men and it's a much more exciting
game to watch and I think if if Sports
Illustrated rope like that and engaged
more people is that just this females
view of it because I can watch
basketball yeah do you like any female
athletics no do I don't let experience
no interested in male sports females for
it's none of it I just I've never been
it's done a ton of play-by-play for
baseball over the years I am just the
baseball queen you know Queen baseball
in Animal Rescue and I love you know
male sports and I don't know I don't
think there should be a female pitcher
in there unless well I've seen some
female underhand pitchers that pitch at
105 you know miles an hour things
instantly and I watched ones a strikeout
gosh Wade Boggs and he was so angry that
he took the next batter spot in the next
batter spot you were doing a charity
game she had to strike him out for three
batters because he wouldn't he refused
to let a woman strike him out and in the
end they just made him sit down so it
would kind of be kind of great if they
did let a woman you know pitch but I
guess underhand and pitch in the big
leagues yeah
and Wade Boggs did not strike out a lot
so he sure didn't say you know she was
you know she was gay yeah that's true
all right well then watch what makes you
happy I guess
the answer there all right oh by the way
I want to remind you guys that the Rubin
report is brought to you by bonobos com
want to get this fine patterned shirt
yes
go to bonobos calm you can get one for
that dude yes and enter code TRR to zero
for 20% off your first purchase and
let's go to the last topic all right I
think you guys are gonna like this one
to male birth control no side effects it
is here a new procedure called
reversible inhibition of sperm under
guidance is a new effective a hundred
percent effective birth control for men
what they do it's an injection into the
base of the scrotum terrible this
pinhole into the scrotum and then they
pull out the vas deferens and then they
do it an injection of this like Joe into
that and then it's supposed to like tear
apart sperm as it passes through that
too thank you thank you for even saying
that instead of having me read it now
this sounds horrific to me but I have a
feeling you two chicks are gonna be okay
with the 100% safe Sam doesn't sound as
bad as supporting a kid you did one for
18 years is true true I I like that
there's an alternative to taking
hormones because some women myself
included I can't handle it like it makes
me crazy right
so it's good to have an alternative but
the question is are guys gonna be
willing to undergo that type of
procedure it is effective for ten years
but it's also reversible reversible yeah
oddly enough it's reversible with an
injection of water and baking soda
apparently the water in baking soda will
get rid of that gel what happens if
someone makes you a cake before you
don't stick your dick in it I think
why I've been so well-behaved here and
out at the end of the show you're
telling me we can speak by the way
four-letter words oh but you're not a
dirty
I'm not are you guys a little jealous
that when they finally come out with a
male thing like this it's so well it's
just easy it can be reversed there's no
problem there's no side effects blah
blah blah 100% infected women you guys
are going through hormones all kinds of
side effects stuff and it's ever been
100% except you know yeah birth control
meaning you're not gonna get it right
yeah yeah yeah birth control definitely
has downsides like the mood swings a lot
of women lose their sex drive when
they're on the pill yeah and hormones
are just terrible to be on for decades
and decades plays havoc with your health
yeah
and you know there's no other thing
that's 100% and you know if this ectomy
was actually snipping the vas deferens
so what's the difference it's it's still
that I'm sure it's under anesthesia it's
probably not as bad as a colonoscopy and
it's five minutes and you're done and
and you're good to go so I think they
should give you a sticker and I voted
and put it on your forehead and which
makes like I look for 18 years from half
the doctors out here well I had one of
those birth control things in the 90s
I'm still filling prescriptions in 2028
like this Pandora's box of crazy things
that could happen because a guy could
say to you oh well I had the procedure
because unless he gets a tattoo or a
stick say that with the vasectomy to
true I guess they could yeah yeah but do
you think maybe it would then open the
door for more STDs to be spread because
people go a woman may say well then he
doesn't have to wear a condom because
I'm not crazy different stories so even
now you know what the vasectomy I mean
it's still the same thing I just think
that you since there's no way to really
know you still have to get up close and
personal and see if you see that little
mark that's what I'm saying there needs
to be some so nice now we'll walk around
lying about it and go I'm not kidding
look and you go you didn't he goes yeah
well yeah that's fine
can you just hold a little longer sorry
but you're holding it I just don't see
guys like lying about it yeah no I don't
think guys are like oh yeah totally I
got a I got those injections and like
purposely our she's pregnant yeah
you think they would live wait till you
start dating oh it's such a big world
Wow guys are gonna lie guys do about
pretty much everything
I mean people lie about of course I
understand that right but a guy doesn't
want to just get a girl pregnant right
like oh but a guy so weird you know a
lot of people have one-night stands and
there's nothing wrong with that and
there are guys who would just say pick
up at someone and say oh yeah I've had
yeah it's way around the world you know
yeah
this almost strikes me as it's like a
little too evolved for Americans right
now this is only done in India right so
it seems like maybe that's okay there
for some reason but American guys I just
don't see American guys you're a guy in
your 20s you're single it doesn't strike
me as something that it'd be great for
marriage because if you're married and
you're committed and then you've had
your kids and you really don't want to
use a condom or your wife is sick of
birth gonna be a great thing too
you know when I met the first person I
ever met who had a vasectomy it was like
such freedom such freedom it was what
she's like I don't to put in contact
lenses anymore it's great I'm just done
using in men ah ok that was purely a
metaphor I don't know what you were
doing it was great when I didn't have to
put in contact lenses or other things
anymore so God ain't know what I mean
and unless you have any final thoughts
thank you
I think that we hashed that out I think
we need to tell our age at the end of
the show how old are you really
22 using a 22 she just looks good 26 see
ya I'm approaching 30 yep yes you're
approaching 30 40 all right no fighting
ladies
I thank you both for joining me this
week wait now a little chance to pimp
yourselves out because you are doing
great things with animals which is my
one soap box baby so tell the people you
can talk directly to camera two well
please go to tails of joy net ta IL s of
joy dotnet it's my own animal rescue an
advocacy organization been doing this
for 16 years and just enjoy the website
learn a little maybe buy a little and I
helped us save a lot of lives from dogs
to cats - bunnies to elephants all over
the United States and beyond and be kind
to animals and spay and neuter because
we kill about eight million a year of
adoptable animals and the only way it'll
stop is spaying and neutering before
they're born because we kill them only
because there's just no place to put
them testify sister and and I pretty
sure everyone knows where they can find
you or Ana Kasparian
cool well thank you guys and actually
there is one more thing one more thing
on the Reuben report here we go what I
thought was cool about bringing you two
together is that even though you guys
are in different fields of work being
women in your respective fields is a
little outside the norm for comedy and
for news and I thought I could get you
both to share a little bit about what
it's like to be a woman in comedy and a
news I just sort of said that on top of
itself news well it's interesting
because Barbara Walters is retiring yeah
and she was the first female anchor so
it kind of gives you a sense of how new
it is for a woman to be in the media and
you know as a woman in the media you
realize that there are certain
advantages that men have over you but
women have certain advantages over men
and so I don't know if it really
balances or balances out but there there
are definitely some challenges but you
just push through and you you become a
trailblazer and you make it easier for
younger generations there are younger
generations to succeed you know you make
it a little easier
for them you're so easy I'm gonna follow
up with that my first comedy a TSA when
you when you started in the comedy scene
young years and the 70s late 70s put in
the buoys and this turns out to be a
webcast I told you the point is so but
with the boom of the eighties yeah and
all this stuff was happening but it
seemed like it happened more for guys so
you know that my theory first of all I
love what you said and and I love that
you're gorgeous and serious and
brilliant because people always separate
it you know when I was starting in the
70s they say oh you're good looking for
a female no no you know it's such an
awful thing but my my take on all of it
has always been you have to be the best
anything you can be and you ignore all
the chatter and just go out and do your
job I you know I really think whoever
can carry you out of the burning
building gets to be the fireman and if
you're catching fire on the 10th floor
and a woman comes up and she can throw
you over her shoulder
you're not gonna say oh no you know
what's a woman fireman she's saving your
life whereas if a man came and couldn't
lift you you go cheek he's not gonna
save my life but at least it's a guy
fireman
you have 10 seconds to be funny onstage
after that that's it they forget what
you are they're laughing and you know no
one ever said oh man she's so funny too
bad it's a woman or oh gee he's not
funny but at least it's a guy do your
job really well and no one can say a
word yeah so my last question on this is
how much do you think that looks play
into the respective fields because if
you look at if you well you certainly
every field but especially you know you
both are public figures and if you were
to turn on Fox News right now every the
men look like garbage basically and the
women all have to look perfect yeah when
it comes to looks and I hate when people
deny that I hate when I make that
statement on the show and guys like no
guys are totally judged by the way
they're that's true to some degree right
but definitely not the same
standard when Mason to them right you
will see gray-haired newscasters with
their beautiful lines and all their life
experience and every woman is like a
potato you know it's it's just not that
you know that it has to change but I
talk I had to talk with my family on
Mother's Day and I was like I got to
come up with a good business idea
something that's sustainable that'll
like it'll be my great plan B and my
mom's like Plan B for what I was like oh
there's not a lot of longevity in my
career like you know at 40 I'm gonna
freak the hell out because no one's
gonna want to hire me and I know that
that sounds really harsh but it's the
reality he has some hot toddy it like 25
is gonna come in and I know that I'm in
that group right now alright she's gonna
come in and some TV exact is gonna be
you're also qualified which makes it
good let's have you watch cable news
though yes but not qualified I know but
Diane Sawyer is not allowed to look like
Andy Rooney you understand the Diane
Sawyer has been pulled I mean I love her
and she's great but she has to do what
she has to do in order to keep her
career Andy Rooney looked like an unmade
bed yeah it was okay because he was
amazing can you imagine if a woman would
have ever come on with those eyebrows
flying everywhere Golda Meir had an
uneven run again because that eyebrows
you know it just doesn't they don't let
you in and studies have shown that
good-looking people are given more
leeway more quarter more respect so it's
just look it's a cosmetic world now it
used to be a cosmetic business now it's
a cosmetic world and you do suffer I
gained weight I'm having trouble I'm
waiting for someone to pay me to lose it
but if they don't don't just have to
lose it but in comedy knows something
there has been some sort of seismic
shift because there was a feeling at one
time that for all camere men and women
that if you were this sort of slovenly
loser that that was funny and now if you
look at all the women that are hot right
now in comedy it's Whitney Cummings and
Sarah Silverman and also go the other
way and a lot of instances it's looks
and no they're not funny and it's really
horrible but when you look at Lenny
Bruce was the stunning man and Richard
Pryor was a gorgeous man and Eddie
Murphy is a gorgeous man
having both will get you further
discussions on comedians
oh not it
run run for your life no no I just think
in every instance looks will get you
further and you know it's and sometimes
it gets you more than you then your
talent will support and look at the
weather my husband runs in every night
for the weather because we call them the
weather strippers from just moving here
for a couple of months you know whether
people in this town what is going on
there meteorology no one is in school
for to be a meteorologist anymore
they're just getting implants and
learning how to point yeah that's it so
the point is if you're not very skilled
but you're willing to do some cosmetic
work become a weather person but if you
are skilled and you're pretty you can
become a comedian or a news anchor and
I'm Dave Rubin that's been the Reuben
report I will see you next week